Sucedieron muchas cosas interesantes
en el mundo del diseño y en IDEO el año pasado,
y me siento complacido de poder compartir algunas de ellas con Uds.
Yo no asistí a la primera versión de TED en 1984
pero he estado en muchas de ellas desde entonces.
Pensé que sería interesante remontarnos a esos tiempos pasados
cuando Richard empezó todo. Muchas gracias, Richard,
venir aquí ha sido parte placentera de mi vida, he disfrutado mucho
Y, siempre recordando, pensaba
en que nosotros en Silicon Valley estábamos enfocados en productos u objetos --
ciertamente, objetos tecnológicos.
Había mucha diversión en esos días,
y algunos de ustedes de la audiencia eran mis clientes.
Llegábamos con algún prototipo bajo una manta negra
y lo colocábamos en la mesa de conferencias,
y luego sacábamos la manta negra y todos exclamaban "ooh" y "ah".
Eran tiempos realmente buenos.
Y continuaremos enfocándonos en los productos, como siempre hemos hecho.
A quienes estuvieron acá el año pasado
probablemente los tumbé al suelo tratando de mostrarles mi nuevo EyeModule 2™
que era una cámara conectada a la Handspring™ (PDA)
Y tomé muchas fotos el año pasado;
muy pocas personas sabían lo qué estaba haciendo, pero tomé muchas fotos.
Este año --quizás podríamos mostrar las diapositivas--
este año trajimos este Treo, con el que tuvimos mucho que ver
y ayudamos a Handspring a diseñarlo.
También, aunque lo diseñamos hace ya algunos años --
sólo se tornó omniprescente hace poco más de un año --
el desfibrilador Heartstream™ que está salvando vidas.
¿Quizás lo vieron en los aeropuertos? Parecen ya estar en todas partes.
Están salvando muchas vidas.
Y estamos a punto de presentar el Zinio Reader
que creo que hará aún más placentera la lectura de revistas.
Así, realmente seguiremos enfocándonos en productos.
Pero algo ha sucedido en los 18 años desde que Richard comenzó con TED,
y es que personas como nosotros --
sé que personas en otros lugares se han involucrado con esto por mucho tiempo,
pero nosotros, recién hemos realmente comenzado a
subiar un poco en la jerarquía de Maslow --
y ahora estamos mucho más enfocados en el diseño centrado en el ser humano
Centrarse en el Humano es una orientación en el diseño
que involucra diseñarles comportamientos y personalidades a los productos.
Pienso que Uds. están comenzando a verlo,
y está haciendo nuestro trabajo aún más gratificante.
Curiosamente, solíamos construir principalmente modelos 3-D --
ustedes lo saben, han visto algunos hoy -- y desarrollos en 3-D.
Y los utilizaríamos para comunicar nuestras ideas.
Pero firmas como la nuestra están necesitando migrar hacia un punto
en el que tomamos esos objetos y los ponemos en movimiento,
mostrando cómo serán utilizados.
Y, para hacerlo, hemos estado formando
grupos internos de producción de video,
para hacer estos prototipos de la experiencia
que muestren exactamente aquello a lo que nos referimos con la relación hombre-máquina.
Es una manera mucho mejor de verlo.
Es como si los arquitectos mostraran sus casas con gente,
en lugar de mostrarlas vacías.
Así que pensé en mostrarles algunos videos
para lucir esta nueva y más ámplia definición
del diseño de productos, servicios y entornos.
Tengo algunos de ellos -- no duran más de un minuto
o minuto y medio cada uno --
pues pensé que estarían interesados en conocer algo de
nuestro trabajo del último año, y cómo se ve en video.
Veamos, Tienda Prada en Nueva York. Rem Koolhaas
y OMA nos pidieron que los ayudemos a concebir la tecnología
que tienen en su tienda de Nueva York.
Querían un nuevo tipo de tienda -- una nueva --
una tienda con un rol cultural, además del rol comercial.
Y eso significaba diseñar tecnología a pedido
en lugar de comprar objetos existentes y utilizarlos.
Hay muchas cosas. Todo tiene etiquetas RF (radio frecuencia):
las tienen los usuarios, las tarjetas,
el personal con dispositivos lectores está por toda la tienda.
Tomas uno y cuando escojes un producto en el que estés interesado
el personal de la tienda lo escanea
y se muestra en cualquiera de las pantallas repartidas por la tienda.
Puedes ver el color, tallas, cómo se excibió en la pasarela o lo que gustes.
Entonces el objeto -- la mercancía de tu interés --
puede ser escaneado. Luego es llevado al vestidor,
y en él también hay escáneres
y así sabemos exactamente qué prendas tiene usted en el vestidor.
podemos colocarlas en una pantalla sensible al tacto
y usted puede jugar con ellas, obtener más información
acerca de la prenda que le interese o que se esté probando.
Ha sido utilizado en muchos lugares, pero me gusta particularmente el empleo que hacen acá
de pantallas de cristal líquido en el cambiador.
La última vez que fui a ver esta tienda,
había un gran alboroto de gente parada afuera preguntándose
"¿Realmente veré a la gente cambiándose de ropa acá?"
Pero, por supuesto, al presionar un botón todo el muro se oscurece.
Así, uno decide si pide o no opiniones sobre lo que se está probando.
Y uno de mis aditamentos tecnológicos favoritos
es el espejo mágico, donde uno se coloca las prendas.
Hay una gran pantalla en el espejo, y uno puede girar --
pero con un retardo de tres segundos.
Así, uno sabe cómo se ve por atrás o al dar la vuelta, uno puede verse.
(Aplausos)
Hace aproximadamente un año y medio nos pidieron diseñar
una instalación en el museo --
es una nueva ala del Museo de Ciencias de Londres,
que trata principalmente sobre asuntos digitales y biomédicos.
Y un grupo en Itch, que es parte de IDEO,
diseñó esta pared interactiva de cerca de 4 pisos de altura.
No se si alguno la habrá visto --
se ve bastante espectacular en la habitación.
Bueno, está basada en el sistema de trenes subterráneos de Londres.
Y podrán ver que
el objetivo es obtener la realimentación
dada por la gente que visita el museo,
y colocarla en un muro donde cualquiera pueda verla. Para que todo el mundo la vea.
Usted ingresa su información. Luego, tal como en el sistema de trenes de Londres,
los pequeños trenes van por ahí con sus pensamientos.
Cuando su mensaje llega a una estación, se expande para que podamos leerlo.
También, cuando usted sale del teatro IMAX en el cuarto piso --
principalmente adolescentes saliendo de ahí --
hay un gran espacio abierto con mesas en él,
que tienen juegos interactivos muy divertidos,
también diseñados por Durrel [Bishop] y Andrew [Hirniak] de Itch.
Y los tópicos incluyen los temas sobre los que trata el museo:
fertilidad masculina, eligiendo el género sexual de su bebé,
o cómo sería un automóvil sin conductor.
Hay mucho espacio, la gente puede venir
y entender de qué se trata antes de involucrarse.
También, aunque no se muestra en el video, estas son preciosas.
Suben hasta lo alto de la pared y cuando llegan ahí,
después de rebotar por todos lados, se dispersan en pedacitos
y desaparecen en la atmósfera.
El siguiente video no lo hicimos nosotros.
Estuvo en CBS Sunday Morning un domingo hace algo de dos semanas.
Scott Adams se nos acercó
y preguntó si podríamos ayudar a diseñar
el mejor cubículo para Dilbert,
lo cual sonaba divertido y no pudimos dejarlo pasar.
Él siempre estuvo interesado en la tecnología del futuro.
(Video: Scott Adams: He notado que en algún momento yo podría ser
el experto mundial en lo que está mal en los cubículos.
Así que pensamos, bueno, ¿no sería divertido juntarnos
con algunos de los muchachos más listos del mundo del diseño
y tratar de descubrir si podríamos mejorar el cubículo?
Narrador: A pesar de trabajar en el amplio espacio de su oficina
ubicada espectacularmente bajo el puente de la Bahía Oakland en San Francisco,
el equipo construyó sus propios pequeños cubículos
a fin de sentir los problemas.
Mujer: Un espejo unidireccional. Yo miro hacia afuera, tu te ves a ti mismo.
Narrador: Tomaron fotografías.
Mujer: Te sientes tan atrapada, cuando alguien medio que se apoya
y te mantiene captiva ahí por un minuto.
SA: Hasta ahora es un caos, pero mucha gente está haciendo cosas, así que es bueno.
Veremos qué sucede.
Narrador: El primer grupo construye un cubículo en el cual las paredes son pantallas
para la computadora y las fotos familiares.
En el escenario del segundo grupo, las paredes están vivas
e incluso le dan a Dilbert un abrazo grupal.
(Risas)
Detrás del humor está la idea de hacer al cubículo más humano.)
David Kelley: Y tenemos el definitivo, completo con luz anaranjada
que sigue al sol a través -- que sigue el rastro del sol -- a través del cielo.
Así lo sientes en tu cubículo.
Mi detalle favorito, que es una flor en un jarrón
que se marchita en desaprobación cuando te vas,
y luego, cuando regresas, se recupera para saludarte, feliz de verte.
(SA: El almacenamiento está incrustado en la pared.)
DK: ¿Saben? Tiene detalles hogareños, como peceras en las paredes,
o algo para agredirlo y relajar la tensión.
(SA: Se puede configurar para el jefe de su elección.)
DK: Y, por supuesto, una hamaca para la siesta vespertina
que se extiende de un lado al otro del cubículo.
(SA: La vida sería dulce en un cubículo como este.)
DK: En el próximo proyecto, nos pidieron diseñar un pabellón para celebrar
el reciclaje de agua, en el Domo del Milenio en Londres.
El domo tiene una increíble cantidad de agua pasando por él
así como agua de deshecho.
Así que este edificio en realidad celebra el agua
que sale de la planta de reciclaje y regresa al canal
para ser filtrada por última vez.
El objetivo de diseño del pabellón era ser silencioso y pacífico.
En contraste con el interior del domo, donde es
más o menos salvaje y alocado y todos
aprenden todo tipo de cosas, o pasean, o hacen lo que sea.
Pero la intención fue hacerlo muy silencioso.
Así, podrías deambular por ahí buscando información,
de manera instintiva, sobre el proceso de reciclaje
y lo que se está haciendo, y cómo van a reutilizar el agua
una vez que salga de la planta.
Y luego, si los vieron,
los paneles rotan. Así que puedes obtener la información
en el lado frontal, pero cuando rotan, puedes ver
la planta de reciclaje atrás, con todas las máquinas mientras impulsan el proceso del agua.
Pueden verla: Ahí está la planta.
Estos son videos de bajo presupuesto, como prototipos rápidos.
Y estamos anunciando acá un nuevo producto hoy
y es la primera vez que es mostrado en público.
Se llama Spyfish (Pez Espía), y su empresa se llama H2Eye,
fundada por Nigel Jagger en Londres,
Y es una compañía que trata de traer la experiencia -- muchas personas tienen botes,
o disfrutan de estar en botes, pero un pequeño porcentaje tiene
la posibilidad real o el interés de ir bajo el agua
y realmente ver lo que está ahí,
y disfrutar lo que hacen los buzos.
Este producto, tiene dos cámaras.
Lo bajas por el lado del bote
y básicamente buceas sin mojarte.
Ese es el objetivo. Para nosotros, eran dos proyectos. El primero, diseñar
la interfaz para que no se cruce en tu camino
Puedes tener esa sensación immersiva de estar bajo el agua --
o sentir que estás debajo del agua -- viendo qué está sucediendo.
Y el otro fue diseñar el objeto
y asegurarnos de que fuera un producto de consumo y no herramienta de investigación.
Así que pasamos mucho tiempo -- hemos estado por algo de
siete u ocho años, en este proyecto --
y estamos listos para comenzar a producirlos.
(Narrador: La Spyfish es una cámara de video subacuática revolucionaria.
Puede sumergirse 500 pies (152 metros) hasta donde no llega la luz solar,
y está equipada con poderosos reflectores.
Se convierte en tus ojos y oidos mientras te aventuras en las profundidades.
Alimentado por baterías, el Spyfish envía la señal de video en vivo por un delgado cable.)
DK: Este cable delgado fue un gran avance tecnológico.
que permitió que todo el aparato tuviera esas dimensiones.
(Narrador: Y esta caja central conecta todos los componentes del sistema.
Manipular el "Spyfish" es simple a través del control remoto inalámbrico.
Puedes ver el video con gráficos sobrepuestos
que indican la profundidad y orientación.
Los gráficos fluídos y el sonido ambiental se combinan
para ayudarte a extraviarte completamente bajo el agua.)
(Aplausos)
DK: Y lo último sobre lo que hablaré es ApproTEC,
que es un proyecto sobre el que estoy muy emocionado.
ApproTEC es una compañía iniciada por el Dr. Martin Fisher,
un gran amigo mío. Es PhD de Stanford.
Estuvo en Kenya con Fulbright
y tuvo una visión muy interesante, en la cual
se dijo: "Debe haber emprendedores en Kenya;
debe haber emprendedores en todas partes."
Y notó que para matrimonios y funerales allá
podían conseguir suficiente dinero como para armar algo.
Así que decidió comenzar a fabricar productos en Kenya
con fabricantes kenianos -- diseñados por gente como nosotros, pero llevados allá.
Y, a la fecha -- Ha estado fuera solo algunos años --
ha comenzado 19,000 compañías.
Ha creado 30,000 nuevos puestos de trabajo.
Y solo las ventas de sus productos -- esto es sin fines de lucro --
la venta de estos productos representa el 0.6% del PBI de Kenya.
Es una persona haciendo esto. Es algo bastante espectacular.
Así que estamos en el proceso de ayudarlos a diseñar
bombas manuales de bajo costo para pozos profundos
para que estas persona que tienen un cuarto de acre de tierra
puedan cosechar fuera de temporada.
Lo que hacen ahora es cultivar en la temporada lluviosa
pero no pueden hacerlo fuera de temporada.
Y al hacer eso, la mujer que vieron primero -- ella es
una maestra de escuela -- siempre quiso enviar a sus hijos a la universidad
y ahora podrá hacerlo, gracias a estas cosas.
Así, con exprimidores de semillas, y bombas, y empacadores de heno y
muchas herramientas elementales que estamos diseñando
-- mis alumnos de Stanford hacen esto como proyectos en clase
e IDEO ha donado el tiempo de sus empleados para hacer este tipo de trabajo --
es impresionante ver su éxito, el de Martin.
Estábamos además pensando sobre la experiencia de Richard,
y, por tanto --
(Risas)
-- diseñamos este sombrero, porque sabía que sería el último del día
y tendría que lidiar con él. Así que solo tengo algo más que decir.
(Risas)
¿Puedes leerlo?
Bueno, siempre es un poco gracioso cuando viene y husmea.
¿Saben? No quieren ser descorteces con él ni sentirse culpables,
así que pensé que esto ayudaría, conmigo acá sentado.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Así que vimos hoy en esta sesión muchas cosas interesantes que están siendo diseñadas
y de todos los diferentes presentadores.
Y en mi trabajo, desde productos hasta ApproTEC,
es muy emocionante que estemos tomando un enfoque más humano hacia el diseño,
que les incluyamos comportamientos y personalidades a los objetos que hacemos,
y pienso que es grandioso.
Los diseñadores son más confiables y estáan más integrados
con las estrategias de negocio de las compañías,
y tengo que decirlo, me siento muy afortunado por el progreso que el diseño
ha logrado desde el primer TED. Muchas gracias.